e
e e
oh thank
you
welcome we're so glad that you're here
uh my name is cat and my pronouns are
she and
her and we are glad that you're here to
worship with us this evening at the
table I have a couple of things that I
need to
announce um first first of all we are
looking to hold a class slw
workshop for folks with relationship and
significant others and there is a QR
code that we would like for you to
please go online and uh fill out some
information about types of
topics and questions and things like
that that that you may have this doesn't
mean you're signing up for anything it
just means we need your input please so
if you have a chance to go online and
and and see the QR code about the
relationship signifant significant other
Workshop that we're holding
um we'd love for you to do that our next
state of the table will be held here
after service on September
29th uh this is where we share what's
going on within our uh table community
and where we can see the health and
strength of each ministry here at the
table uh all are
welcome these
candles are a sign of the presence of
Christ Among Us
that's okay
and I'll repeat these
candles are a sign of the presence of
Christ Among Us fully
Divine and fully
human please stand as you're able and
willing as we go into our time of
worship
[Music]
gracious God we come before you today as
a family of
Believers grateful for the privilege of
gathering in your
presence as we embark on this time of
worship May our Unity be a reflection of
your presence Among
Us bless each Soul present here and may
our worship bring joy to your
heart may love find
you find
us may we all come
[Music]
home thank you Cat as you guys are
standing we're going to go ahead and
start our worship time together this is
um a gift for us to be able to sing with
you guys um so I hope that this little
wall that's between you and and I can
kind of dissolve in our minds and we can
enter into this space as a group
activity as a community who's coming
before a loving God and speaking out
truths that we believe sustain us and
Hold Us fast through our weeks so we
just invite you into this time together
with us we're going to start with um a
song that kind of has like a little
Acappella amen part at the beginning and
amen means may it be so so it's kind of
like this statement that we're
proclaiming as we enter into worship
that the things that we're going to say
and sing We want to be true for us here
so you guys can join in as you're
able
aen
amen
[Music]
amen am amen let's do that again
together sing it
[Music]
out
amen
amen last
time
amen
amen oh falling down like P love that I
can explain a peace that Stills my
soul light in the darkest Place light
even in the pain it feels like coming
home where the spirit of the Lord is
there is
freedom I am
created sing that again where the spirit
of the Lord is there is
freedom I am free
amen you I'm alive again God is the way
to send all sweet
Liberty praise God who save my life I'm
B with the blood of Christ
have been
redeemed where the spirit of the Lord is
there is
freedom I am free
amen where the spirit of the Lord is
there is
freedom I am free am sing it one more
time where the spirit of the Lord is
there is
freedom I am free
amen where the spirit of the Lord is
there is
freedom I am
free free at last free at last than God
Almighty I am free at last
oh my chains are in the last they God
Almighty I am free and last everybody
now free at last free and last than God
Almighty I am free at last all my chains
are in the past than God Almighty I am
free at last everybody sing free at last
free at last God Mighty I am
fre oh my CHS are in the past God
Almighty I am free at
last
oh I am
feeless I'm feel like
where the spirit of the Lord is there is
freedom I am free
amen yeah where the spirit of the Lord
is there is
freedom I am free
amen all right kiddos you can be
dismissed here your
classes your teachers will oh sorry I
got to
sneeze your teachers will join you over
by the doors thank you kids ministry
team so much for loving on our
kiddos me and Kelly and
Brock and I think Maggie is gonna come
up and Brett yall can take a seat I know
this is a little bit un a little
different
normal uh or a different Rhythm than
normal but um I wanted to take a moment
to um talk about a really significant
transition that's happening in the life
of our church community so many of you
know for the last it's been maybe two
years two it's been a while that we've
had a a youth Meetup um which has really
been kind of even more than like a even
a kind of a normal Meetup it's um it's
really been sort of like the beginnings
of a youth ministry
and um we have kind of a leadership
transitioning happening where Maggie um
who has been leading this ministry now
for for a few years along with um some
other adults um but she's been the point
leader for it is um kind of handing over
the Reigns to Anna Anna Potter do you
want to come on up as
well y'all give her a
hand so so we kind of wanted to do a
dual thing here where I wanted to say
first thank you Maggie this is from the
table Community thank you uh we love you
lots and are so grateful for all you've
given and also want to name hooray we're
so excited for Anna to be transitioning
so mag do you want to um speak to Anna
for a moment yes well if y'all can't
hear fan club from the back of the
room my baby yeah Anna's actually
graduating with her kids is the truth
true Anna's been working in kids
ministry for the last two years and I
mean really has served in most age
groups but particularly has tuned into
those older kiddos and um I mean I there
were a few months back when we were
congratulating our sixth graders who
were graduating in seventh grade and
Anna was in tears and the rest of us
were like congratulations she said so
she's decided to go with them um but she
has been very faithful ful serving in
kids ministry carrying much larger load
than just as a weekly volunteer um many
times taking on the full point role like
at all of July when I was out Anna was
stepping in Anna has a incredible
administrative gifts she's also an
educator so she's very well versed in
how to do this and works with these kid
specifically this age group all the time
and that's really where her heart has
been for quite a while and now her heart
is matching up with our need so um
anyways if you guys would join me Anna's
going to be supported by her wife Devon
and they're definitely a Duo like a
dynamic duo and they do almost
everything together um except for
moments like this where Devon is
coaching softball and Anna has to leave
early so she can come here for this so
you can imagine Devon up here as well um
but if you guys will just extend your
hand pray with me and I just want to
bless her as she moves into this role so
God I'm very very deeply grateful for
Anna and honestly just on a personal
level knowing the story of her life and
the journey you've had her on the ways
that you have very uniquely prepared her
to minister to teens to um to see with
um really god-given
eyes who people are and how to Value
them them how to lead them to you um
with patience and also with passion and
God I just ask that you would um allow
Anna's natural giftings and talents and
the just the heartbeat of her life to
just flow naturally as she moves into
this new role and we thank you we ask
that you would give Grace in her
marriage in in her job um in in her
everyday life as she takes on a new load
and a new responsibility God I ask that
you would also just make space and room
um for all that she has um stored up in
her heart for these teens and um God I
just pray that you would be with her be
with Devon and be with our teams be with
um the students who call the table home
and and may it become a safe place and a
home for so many more in Jesus name we
pray amen amen thank you Anna
all right well we're going to hand it
back to Mindy and um if you're a teen in
the room tonight and you fall between
seventh grade and 12th grade they will
be meeting in the back um so find Anna
and she can give you more
[Music]
details all right do you guys want to go
ahead and stand back up with
us this song is really better on our
feet
[Music]
you would help Gary if I had the
metronome raise a
hallelu in the pr presence of my
enemies I'll raise a
hallelu louder than the
unbelief I raise a
Hallelujah my weapon is a
Melody I raise a hallelu
Heaven comes to fight for
me I'm going to sing in the middle of
the
storm louder and louder you're going to
hear my Praises Ro Up From the
Ashes hope will
arise death is
defeated the king is alive
[Music]
I'll raise a
hallelu with everything inside of
me I raise the
Hallelujah I will watch The Darkness
flee
[Music]
praise the
Hallelujah in the middle of the
mystery I raise the
Hallelujah feel You've Lost Your hold on
me I'm going to sing to the middle of
the
storm louder and louder going to hear my
praise
is Up From the
Ashes hope will
arise death is
defeated the king is alive that again
I'm to sing in the middle of the
storm louder and louder going to hear my
Praises From the
Ashes hope will
arise death is defeated
King is
[Music]
alive sing a little
louder sing a little
louder sing a little louder
sing a little
louder sing a little
louder presence of my enemy sing a
little
louder the sing a little
louder my weapon is a Melody sing a
little
louder heav comes to fight for me sing a
louder in the presence of of my enemy
sing a little
louder louder than the unbel sing a
little
louder my weapon is a Melody to
Lou Heaven com f for me sing a little
louder I'm going to sing in the middle
of the
storm louder and louder going to hear my
Praises Ro Up From the Ashes hope will
arise death is defeated the king is
alive I'm going to sing in the middle of
the
storm lder and louder going to hear my
Praises Ro Up From the Ashes hope will
arise death is defeated the king is
alive
[Music]
all right I wanted to read a scripture
really quickly Brett actually sent it
out to some of our um volunteers this
morning and I went and looked up the
verses around it and it just was one of
those songs to I mean one of those
verses to me that's a lot like that song
um that's recognizing the struggle and
the opportunity for us to meet God in
the middle of sometimes what's not
always a Mountaintop what's not always
the easy parts of life but some of the
pain and some of the loneliness some of
the um more difficult
challenges it says because of the Lord's
great love we are not
consumed for his compassions never fail
they are new every morning great is your
faithfulness the Lord is good to those
whose hope is in him the ones who seek
him so it is good to wait quietly for
the Salvation of the lord it's good for
man to Bear the Yoke let him sit alone
in silence for the lord has laid it on
him let him bury his face in the dust
there may yet
be hope let him offer his cheek to the
one who would strike him and let him be
filled with disgrace for men are not
cast off by the Lord forever though he
brings grief he will show
compassion so great is his unfailing
[Music]
love love you Lord
for your mercy never fails
me and all my
days I've been H in your
hand from the moment that I wake
up until I lay my
head I will
see of the
goodness of God
all my life you have been
[Music]
Faith all my life you have been so so
good with every breath that I
am I will
see of the
goodness of God
I love your
voice you have led me through the
fire in Darkest
Night you are close like no
other I've known you as a
father I've known you as a
friend I
have in the goodness of God
[Music]
oh my life you have been
faithful oh my life you have been so so
good with every breath that I
en I will
see of the goodness of God
I will
see of the
goodness of
[Music]
God your goodness is running out it's
running out after
me your goodness is running after it's
running after
me my life laid down and surrender now I
give you
everything your goodness is running
after it's running after me sing that
again your goodness is running after
it's running after
me your goodness is running after it's
running after
me my life laid down and surrender now I
give you everything
your goodness is running after it's
running after
me
oh it's running after
[Music]
me oh my life you have been faithful
oh my life you have been so so
good with every breath that I
am I will
see of the
goodness of God I will sing I will sing
of the
goodness of
God I will
sing of the
goodness of
[Music]
God God we continue to sing of your
goodness when we're sitting alone god
with our face in the
dust when we're
rejoicing in our community together
remembering some of the good things that
you have done God we continue to sing to
you we continue continue to reach out to
a god that we believe will
respond a God who sees
us a God who knows us and a God who
loves
[Music]
us meet us here in this moment in Jesus
name
amen would you guys turn to the people
around you and say hello make them feel
at home and then we'll get going
well Grace and peace it is good to be
with you all um my name is Brett I'm the
pastor here and uh yeah it's a joy a joy
to welcome you into this space and as
always that includes those joining us
online yall are not forgotten love you
lots and um anyone here tonight who is
new thank you for um coming into this
space I know it can just it can just be
a lot coming through those double doors
and uh all sorts of feelings and so yeah
we're just really grateful that that
you're here uh with us so uh I'm really
honored tonight to get to introduce uh a
very good friend of mine Reverend Denise
Mason who is going to be bringing the
word of the Lord uh who's going to be
preaching um tonight and um um she is um
man if you haven't heard her speak like
the the thing I one of the things I
appreciate um about Denise is she is um
deeply authentic just always herself and
I think there's something about um
pastoral Ministry and and she um leads a
community uh Pleasant Valley United
Methodist Church whose space we used to
rent in in um we're there for many years
um and there's something about pastoral
Ministry that kind of lends itself
towards
a little like inauthenticity where you I
don't know people maybe have
expectations so you just start to kind
of become whoever people want you to
become you know to try to keep everyone
happy and that's the thing I appreciate
about Denise is she is herself and it's
just it's a joy and a delight she just
has an energy um about her that I just
really appreciate so um would you all
give her a hand as she comes up tonight
[Applause]
thank you whoa I think we got too
close
well oh I'm very
loud so I'm want to just thank you first
for having me thank you Brett and um
everything he said right back at him
because um I just got to tell you how
much I love you guys and those of you
don't know me when you used to meet at
Pleasant Valley I miss you every Sunday
I miss you so no that I pray for you
every Sunday and I'm just so very
pleased to be here with you um my
scripture today is taken from the book
of Genesis and it is chapter 21 it's
verses 8-
21 if you will hear now these
words the child grew and was weaned and
Abraham made a great feast on the day
that Isaac was
weaned but Sarah saw the son of Hagar
the Egyptian whom she had born to
Abraham playing with her son Isaac so
she said to Abraham cast out this slave
woman with her son for the son of this
slave woman shall not inherit along with
my son
Isaac the matter was very distressing to
Abraham on account of his son but God
said to Abraham do not be distressed
because of the boy and because of your
slave woman whatever Sarah says to you
do as she tells you for it is through
Isaac that offspring shall be named
after you as for the son of the slave
woman I will make a nation of him also
because he is your
Offspring so Abraham Rose early in the
morning and took bread and a skin of
water and gave it to Hagar putting it on
her shoulder along with the child and
sent her
away and she departed and wandered about
in the wilderness of
berseba when the water in the skin was
gone she cast the child under one of the
bushes then she went and sat down
opposite him a good way off about the
distance of a bow shot for she saido not
let me look upon the death of my
child and as she sat opposite him she
lifted up her voice and she
wept and God heard the voice of the boy
and the angel of God Called to Hagar
from heaven and said to her what
troubles you
Hagar do not be afraid for for God has
heard the voice of the boy where he is
come lift up the boy hold him fast with
your hand for I will make a great nation
of
him then God opened her eyes and she saw
a well of water she went and filled the
skin with water and she gave the boy a
drink God was with the boy and he grew
up and he lived in the wilderness and
became an expert with the bow he lived
in the wilderness of parin and his
mother got a wife for him from the land
of
Egypt this is God's word for God's
people today thanks be to God would you
pray with
me come Holy Spirit May the words of my
mouth and the meditations of our hearts
be acceptable in your sight our Rock and
Our
Redeemer
amen so a while back I took my
grandchildren to the zoo now I don't
know if you've noticed but doesn't
matter how many times or how much you
pay to get into the zoo the kids always
seem to want to do that one thing that
is not included in the price anybody
been there yes you know in this case it
was the merrygoround a ride that lasts
all about 41 seconds and it cost a $150
per kid please Nana they beg please
please and because I'm a grandma well I
shelled out the cash and I watched as
they clambered on and tried to find the
one horse or whatever it was they wanted
to sit on the one that they liked the
best and let me just say that almost led
to
Bloodshed but eventually they were on
and the ride
started and as the first grandchild went
by me she waved at me and I waved back
then the second kid did the same and I
waved back again and on and on it went
every time they came around to where I
was they waved at me frantically and I
waved
back and as I looked around I I noticed
that all the other kids were doing the
same thing with their parents or
grandparents or whoever was with them
and all of a sudden it struck me as
really
strange I mean a whole slew of kids
waving frantically and another slew of
adults all waving frantically back
smiling as if these kids were leaving on
a three-year-long vacation or
something why is this a thing I thought
why I mean it's a pretty common
phenomenon I'm sure that we've all seen
it and done it before but it's slightly
weird isn't
it later on that night my curiosity got
the best of me and it led me to the
source of all great knowledge here on
Earth and not God but Google and I
looked it up and I said why do kids wave
at their parents on a
merrygoround now I have to admit I was a
little surprised to find that apparently
I'm not the only one to have asked that
question I came across a lot of
interesting articles but many of those
articles they quoted this man named
William tus who's an award-winning
journalist and he's an author and he
said you don't really understand human
nature unless you know why a child on a
merrygoround will wave at his parents
every time they go around and why his
parents will wave back at
him it seems that we're born with this
innate need to know that we are
special right anyone who has a kid or or
was a kid is familiar with the off
repeated words look at me look at me
watch Me While I jump watch me skip
watch me do just about anything look at
me we all want to be noticed right we
want to be noticed Just The Way We
Are The Very Girl M may not go anywhere
but every time we lose sight of our
parents or our grandparents are waving
at them and they're waving back at us
assures us we're not alone we're special
there is someone out there who sees us
someone we belong to someone who's
waiting for us someone who loves
us and this is what good parents and
grandparents aunts and uncles do right
we wave every time the kids come around
because we want them to know we see them
we see who they are we see that they're
special they're loved because they're
ours and maybe that's why this story
from our scriptural lesson today was one
that for so many years bothered me so
greatly because as great of a man as
Abraham was well this story is quite
appalling isn't
it frankly it's almost a primer in how
to be a bad
parent our text be begins in the in the
middle of a much larger Story one that
details God's choosing and Blessing of
Abraham God's promise that his
descendant would outnumber the stars and
that through him all nations would be
blessed there was however a small little
problem one that was very apparent to
both Abraham and his wife Sarah and that
was that Sarah could not have
children God may have promised this vast
number of descendants but neither
Abraham nor Sarah could fathom any way
that that could
happen so Sarah comes up with a
plan surrogacy
now this may seem to be a modern thing
surrogacy but reent recent
archaeological digs have shown that or
have found these clay tablets they are
kind of like little contracts that um
states that if a couple does not produce
a child within two years they can then
look for a surrogate to Bear a child so
the husband's name Will Go On Now this
these go back way way very very
ancient now slaves were were used as
surrogates not not like today they
didn't get paid they were used for
surrogates because in the world of the
ancient near East a slave person was
subhuman a slave woman was nothing more
than an incubator or womb with
legs now we don't know if Abraham and
Sarah had a contract such as this but
the point is that surrogacy seems to
have been quite common back then and in
their case they'd been married way
longer than two years and Sarah
realizing that she's not going to
conceive well she decides to take
matters into her own hands and takes her
Egyptian slave who is a young girl named
Hagar and gives her to
Abraham and soon Hagar becomes
pregnant now the scripture tells us that
when Hagar conceived she looked with
contempt upon her
mistress now to us this kind of sounds
like a snotty kid doesn't it like she's
somehow better than Sarah now
but it's really important for us to
understand that this was it was quite
women uh sorry quite common for women
who were Barren to be looked down upon
in those days you see it was a common uh
uh conception that if you could not have
children there was something wrong with
you and that's why the gods had kept you
from being
pregnant now before Hagar was given to
Abraham well she would have kept quiet
about this right because she's just a
slave girl but now that she's pregnant
well she has a little bit more leeway
she is carrying the air she is carrying
Abraham's
child and she thinks because she is she
has a certain
protection but the scripture tells us
that her looking with contempt upon
Sarah makes Sarah very angry and she
goes to Abraham and tells
him your slave girl is looking at me
funny
she's looking at me funny and Abraham
tells herw do whatever you need to do do
whatever you need to do she's your slave
girl
Sarah so Sarah
does and we're told that Sarah deals
with Hagar
harshly now fast forward a few years and
Hagar has given birth to a son they
named Ishmael which mean which means God
hears God hears and Ishmael is the apple
of his dad's eye
then the impossible happens for Sarah a
miracle she conceives as God told her
she would and she gives birth to a child
a boy she names Isaac which means he
laughs she's thrilled it it's everything
she ever wanted but there's this little
fly in the ointment for
Sarah that pesky older kid that older
son
Ishmael and the text tells us that Sarah
looks up and she sees Ishmael playing
with her
son now this is interesting because it's
a direct play on words here the words
used for playing or the word used for
playing is the same as the root of
Isaac's name in other words what it
means is Sarah saw him laughing with the
one who
laughs and this sight makes Sarah see
red and she marches over and she demands
Abraham get rid of this kid and her
mother too or his mother too and her
eyes this kid is beneath her child he
has no business laughing with her child
as if he's
somebody after all he's only the son of
a lowly slave girl and now that Sarah's
son has been born well Ishmael is no
longer needed is he he has no right to
take anything from her son I mean never
mind she gave Hagar to Abraham she is
the rightful wife her child is the one
who deserves
everything now Sarah behavior is
horrible but what happens next is the
part of the story that really has
Disturbed me for so
long Abraham is the father of this
innocent child
Ishmael but th though we're told that
he's upset by what Sarah is demanding
out of him he doesn't say
no his child's life hangs in the balance
but he just sits there agonizing over
what to
do the fact that a father would would
even consider doing this as disturbing
enough but as he is agonizing over it it
gets worse God tells him do what Sarah
said send the boy away with his
mother for it is through Isaac God says
that The Offspring shall be named after
you then he tacks on right at the end as
for the son of the slave woman I will
make a nation of him also because he is
your Offspring too
why would God do
this why would God who's often called
our Heavenly Father tell Abraham to
abandon his son to send him off into the
Wilderness a place where death seemed
certain and what about this poor slave
girl who has no choice in the matter is
she just
disposable this passage nagged and
nagged at me until one day as I was
reading through the story again I
noticed something
a little detail that didn't seem all
that important at the time until you put
it together with the rest of the
story it happens way back at the
beginning of the whole
thing see when Hagar first gets pregnant
with Ishmael and Sarah begins abusing
her while Hagar runs away only to be
sent back by
God the text says that she runs to the
spring of water in the wilderness and
the angel of the Lord finds her there
now the title Angel of the Lord in the
the Book of Genesis is often
interchangeable with that of God so
essentially God finds Hagar at the
spring of water and God says
Hagar where have you come from and where
are you
going she said well I'm running away
from my mistress
Sarai God tells her to go on back and
Promises her that I will so greatly
multiply your offspring that they cannot
be counted for
multitude now this is a bit surprising
because it's the same promise that God
made to
Abraham but it's what happened next that
really caught my
attention see Hagar's encounter with God
is so powerful that she gives God a new
name a name that expresses her
experience of God El
Roi which means the God who sees
me the God who sees the slave girl who
can be given to a man without her
consent the slave girl who's a a
foreigner a stranger in this land the
slave girl with no rights
whatsoever the God who sees
her this is so powerful see God sees her
and after his birth God sees her son and
when Sarah demands that they leave well
God tells Abraham to let let them go
why because God sees her God sees Ismael
and God also sees sees
Sarah and he sees Sarah's
wrath God sees he sees the horrible
situation they are in God sees that
nothing good can happen for them if they
stay so God tells Abraham to let them
go and the next morning Abraham does
just that he sends them both off into
the Wilderness and Hagar wanders
aimlessly until the water she had been
given runs out and without water well
she knows that her son will die very
quickly she can't bear to watch it so
she puts him under a bush and she goes
as far away as she
can so she won't hear him
crying then she sits down and starts to
weep she's
alone she's
vulnerable and once again she has no
Sayo in what happens to her she can do
nothing more than just sit and wait for
the
inevitable but as she sits crying a
voice suddenly calls out to
her what troubles you
Hagar now that seems to be a pretty
silly question doesn't it I mean I'm
sitting in the middle of a Wilderness
with no water just waiting for my son to
die what do you mean what troubles
me but the voice says don't be
afraid for God hears the voice of your
child child God hears Ishmael God
hears go on get the boy hold on to him
for I will make a great nation of
him God
sees Hagar may have forgotten
elroi but the God who sees her has not
forgotten
her God sees and God hears God hears the
cries of those who are suff uing and God
sees the one that no one else seems to
care
about the ones who others treat as
disposable God
sees and then the text tells us that God
opens Hagar's eyes and she sees a well
of water a well that had likely been
there but somehow she didn't manage to
see it
why maybe it was her hopelessness that
blinded
her her feeling of to desolation and
certainty that nobody
cared the Zulu tribe in Africa has a
very Africa has a very interesting way
of greeting one another instead of
saying hello they say
saona it's a word that means I see you
and the person being greeted answers in
jaona which means I am
here as always when translating from one
language to another critical uh uh
crucial sub uh subtleties boy my mouth
won't work crucial subtleties are lost
and in the uh inherent in the Zulu
greeting is this saona is the idea that
I see the whole of you I see your
experiences I see your passions I see
your pain your strengths and your
weaknesses and I see your
future you are valuable to
me likewise the response in jaona had
the underlying sense of that until you
saw
me I didn't
exist by recognizing me you have brought
me into
existence and I wonder if that was not
the case with
Hagar she wasn't able to see until she
knew that she was
seen as if before she was seen she
really didn't exist
did you notice that neither Abraham nor
Sarah ever refers to Hagar by
name Sarah calls her my slave girl and
Abra Abraham calls her your slave
girl it's as if she's a
non-person her name doesn't matter
because she's a
nobody in fact the only time she is
called by name is when El Ro I
speaks what troubles you
Hagar God says I see you
Hagar I care about your pain you are not
a nobody you are a
somebody you are my child and I love
you you are not alone I am with you I am
with your son he may have been a mistake
to Abraham and Sarah but he is not a
mistake to me
and I will make of him and you a great
nation Hagar is
seen and because she is seen she sees
her eyes are open to what is right in
front of her and she gives her son some
water and off they
go to a better life where she's no
longer a
slave but a treasured
Mother where Ishmael is no longer The
Unwanted son
but the treasured
son now most of us are not in a
situation like
Hagar but I wonder how many of us either
go through life or through times in our
lives that we feel
invisible we don't
matter how many of us put on a good face
while wishing that someone would see the
pain we're in or the suffering we're
going
through how many of us feel abandoned or
unworthy or in some way
inferior my friends I want you to know
tonight God sees
you God sees you God sees you on the
merrygoround of life and God does more
than
wave God is on the ride with you God
never lets you out of his sight God is
there God sees your suffering God sees
your pain God sees your sorrow sorrow
God sees you
you in the wilderness places of life
when it seems like the world and those
in it have turned their backs on
us we're not abandoned my
friends it is in those times that maybe
God is trying to get us to see a new way
A New Path that that we couldn't have
possibly imagined
before so this evening I pray you will
let your hearts absorb these words that
you will open open up your ears to hear
God call your
name
saona I see
you in the name of the father and of the
son and of the holy
spirit
amen sorry I'm having a little
conversation with Brett here on the
we're preparing to enter into a time of
Holy Communion over there um and my my
friends this is a time if
you this is a time where you are certain
God sees you this is Christ's table this
is a table where everyone is welcome
this is a table where everyone's name is
known God sees you here God meets you
here in the bread and the
wine I know in my church and I know in
this church everyone is welcome no one
is turned away from this table
so I pray that um you will hear now
these words what we call the words of
institution which I'm going to say over
the these gifts of bread and wine but
first would you pray with
me loving
God we confess that we have not loved
you with our whole
heart we have failed in so many things
we have not done your will we've broken
your law we have rebelled against your
love and we have not loved our neighbors
we've not heard the Cry of the
needy but God forgive us we
pray free us with your
grace so that we can be who you call us
to
be and we ask it all in the name of
Jesus Christ Our
Lord
amen so my friends on the night in which
he was betrayed our our Lord took
bread he broke the bread he gave it to
his disciples and he said Take and Eat
This is my body which was broken for you
do this every time you eat it in
remembrance of
me and after the supper was over he took
the cup he gave thanks to you oh God and
gave it to his disciples and said take
and
drink this is my blood which is poured
out for you
do this in remembrance of
me and so in remembrance of these your
Mighty acts in Jesus Christ we offer
ourselves oh God in praise and
thanksgiving as a holy and Living
Sacrifice in Union with Christ's
offering for
us we ask now that you would pour out
your Holy Spirit on us gathered here and
on these gifts of bread and wine make
them be for us the body and blood of
Christ that we may be for the world the
body of Christ redeemed by his blood by
your spirit make us one with Christ one
with each other and one in Ministry to
all the world until Christ comes in
final Victory and we Feast at his
heavenly banquet through your son Jesus
Christ with the Holy Spirit and your
holy church all honor and glory is yours
almighty God now and
forever
amen as children of God can we all now
pray the prayer that our Lord taught us
to pray
Our Father who art in heaven Hallowed be
thy name thy kingdom come thy will be
done on Earth as it is in heaven give us
this day our daily bread and forgive us
our trespasses as we forgive those who
trespass against us and lead us not into
temptation but Deliver Us from Evil for
thine is the kingdom and the power and
the glory
forever amen
the bread over which we give thanks is a
sharing in the body of
Christ and the cup over which we give
thanks is a sharing in Christ's
Blood come as you're able
[Music]
just
we're going to close with for everyone
born um and as we sing these words um
just like Hagar let's just remember that
there is space for you there is space
for each of us and we want to create
that space for others here in our
community and in our lives so you guys
are welcome to stand and sing these
words with us if you'd like or however
you feel
comfortable for everyone
born a place at the
table to everyone born clean water and
bread a shelter a
space a safe place for
growing for everyone
born a star over
head and God will
when we are
creators of
justice and
joy
compassion and
peace yes God will Delight when we are
creators of
justice justice and joy
for woman and
men a place at the
table revising the
roles
deciding the
share with wisdom and
Grace
diving the
poers for
genders a system that's p
[Music]
are
stength a place at the
table a covenant
Shar a
welcoming
space a rainbow of
Grace of gender and
color for gay and for
strength a chalice of of
Grace and God will Delight when we are
creaters of justice and
joy
compassion and
peace yes God will Delight when we are
creators of
justice justice and joy
jce
[Music]
and for young and for
old a place at the
table a voice to be
heard aart in the
S the hands of a child in hands that are
wrinkled for young and for old
the right to be
L and God will Delight when we are
creators of justice and
joy
compassion and peace yes God will
Delight when we are
creators of
Justice Just J and
joy jusice and
joy Justice and
joy Justice
[Music]
we want to thank you for being here this
evening if you are new we would love to
for you to fill out a card located on
that table and just to um thank you for
being here reach out to you and thank
you for being here and answer any
questions that you may
have if you are in need of a
hug a qu you have any questions General
support to talk please find me after the
service I'm here for you and I'd love to
be here for to support
you generosity is a key aspect of life
and adoration and worship to give
financially you can scan the QR code or
visit the table at tx.org
all right let me send you now uh into
your week with this blessing you can
hold out your hands in a posture to
receive or just open your heart to these
words you are a child of
God you are a child of
God this is
true on your best
day and this is true on your worst day
so as you go go into your week ahead
with it's yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are
loved and you are worthy and you are
accepted just as you are and
go filled with God's Holy Spirit and the
desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact
with be
blessed have a good
week you are
seen and we hope to see you back next
year here next
Sunday good
night for
[Music]
everyone of at the table
to live without fear it's simply to
be to work to speak out to witness and
worship for everyone
born the right to be
[Music]
free for just and
unjust a place at the table
abuser
abused with need to
forgive in anger and hurt a might and of
Mercy for just and
unjust a new way to
live it's God with delight when we are
creators of jce and
joy
compassion and peace yes God will
Delight when we are
creators of
justice justice and
joy Justice in jcece
Justice and
[Music]
joy love the sounds even the back
directing sorry Kaitlyn sorry sorry